[Musica]
c'è la rigenerazione urbana la
rigenerazione cellulare la rigenerazione
spirituale
e poi c'è tipo di rigenerazione di cui
vorrei parlare oggi vi piace chiamarla
la rigenerazione di seneca la
caratteristica principale di questo tipo
di rigenerazione e che le persone che la
stanno vivendo non se ne rendono conto
anzi si sentono sprofondare avete
presente quei periodi in cui è tutto
troppo stancante in cui non c'è la
voglia di alzarsi la mattina per
cominciare una nuova settimana perché si
sa già che sarà stressante ci saranno
mille cose da fare ma non ci sarà
entusiasmo
ecco in quei periodi arriva sempre il
momento in cui decidiamo di stato re a
spina e allora se possiamo abbiamo in
vacanza o altrimenti andiamo a fare una
gita fuori porta una cena fuori
ecco rimaniamo lì al momento in cui
torniamo a casa la sera
e chiudiamo gli occhi nel letto e
realizziamo che il giorno dopo dovremo
tornare alla nostra vita di tutti i
giorni e che non ne abbiamo nessuna
voglia c'è un motivo che ci sentiamo in
questo modo e c'è alcuna cura se
vogliamo chiamarla così però andare a
prenderci la dobbiamo tornare al primo
secolo dopo cristo alla roma imperiale
la roma di scenica se ne capo un
filosofo storico che disse a stretto
contatto con tre imperatori due dei
quali sono ricordati come i più crudeli
e fogli di tutta la storia di roma
caligola e nerone e vivendo a stretto
contatto con la corte secca che era un
grande osservatore osserva quelli che
oggi definiremmo i romani della roma
bene l'esponente di spicco della società
e come erano seneca riprende un po in
giro li definisce gli occupati erano
persone molto stressate sempre sempre
piaciuta agli affari sempre in attesa di
nuovi progetti sotto pressione senza
tempo per se stessi a me sembra la vita
che viviamo oggi è certamente
tranquillità the army raccontante che
anche loro sentivano il bisogno di
andare in vacanza sentano il bisogno di
staccare e allora andavano in campana
per cercare un po di potenza che però si
stampavano della raffinatezza e allora
andavano in calabria a cercare terra più
selvagge poi però si stancavano anche
della calabria abbiamo ancora cambiavano
ancora e poi alla fine tornavano a roma
senza essere sia fatto che genera
volevano cambiare certi cambiavano
compagnia cambiavano meta turistica ma
quel senso di insoddisfazione perenne
che provavano dentro non cambiava mai
seneca con una grande intuizione che
anticipa la psicologia di fine novecento
capito perché questi romani settimane in
questo modo e o riassunse in due parole
ali ager fare altro benché senso fare
altro può sembrare strano ma fare altro
è alla base di uno dei più importanti
meccanismo della nostra mente
l'evitamento
detto in parole semplici e foch brucia
scotta è non toccare fai altro ai lager
e il risamento alcun meccanismo molto
utile in certe situazioni in altre però
può essere dannoso prendiamo giulia
giuliana ragazza che oggi il suo lavoro
e così stressata che mai venuta l'area
spetta però giulia dice che è soltanto
un periodo difficile invece con l'amica
per non pensarci per evitare di soffrire
a ridarle però è l'italia di soffrire
non equivale a stare bene e ora siamo
tutti bravi e giulia sbaglia e che
dobbiamo affrontare i nostri problemi
siamo bravi a dirlo si ma a farlo prima
richiesto se anche voi sono tornati
dalle vacanze vi sentite come se non
arresto per niente voglia di tornare
alla vita di tutti i giorni
ecco siamo altri sentite così è perché
state evitando qualcosa e non c'è niente
di sbagliato capiamo non è una colpa
perché non dimentichiamoci che
l'evitamento è un meccanismo molto
potente inconsapevole e
probabile che nella volta nella vita a
noi avendo approvato però il punto è che
nasce per cercare di trovare un sollievo
un attimo di respiro a quell attimo dura
sempre troppo poco e come se non
bastasse c'è un effetto collaterale la
nostra mente la metto in campo perché
pensa che non saranno in grado di
gestire la sofferenza derivata dalla
cosa che stiamo cercando di riparare e
se noi assecondiamo evitamento le
comunichiamo che fa per così in effetti
non siamo in grado di gestire quella
sofferenza sequel fuoco brucia troppo
noi non sopportiamo con il dolore il
punto però è che possiamo paragonare la
nostra mente ad una stanza e il fuoco
nella nostra stanza mentali non smetterà
di bruciare e la temperatura nella
stanza senza era sempre di più e allora
noi cercheremo la maggiore di riordinare
la scrivania di telefonare un amico ma
niente da fare la temperatura senza
sempre di più e allora sentiamo il
bisogno di respirare da quell attimo di
sollievo di respiro e stacchiamo la
spina andiamo in vacanza ma prima o poi
dovremo tornare nella stessa stanza
notare dovremmo tornare alla nostra vita
e magari ci sentiremo anche un po
sciocchi debole perché non siamo
riusciti a spegnere quel fuoco ma siamo
riusciti a dovere la lista che volevamo
e allora come si esce da questa
situazione
meglio ancora come sia pronta perché
arrivato il momento di affrontare
torniamo a giulia la ragazza per le
feste il suo lavoro
ecco il suo cuoco e ovviamente questo il
suo odiato lavoro e quando ci pensa
giuliano in passato insieme come te lo
devi far piacere a questo lavoro guarda
che un lavoro oggi è una fortuna
accontentati è che questi pensieri sono
come il fumo preferisco la gioia di
vedere chiaramente e poi quando ci
sentiamo attorniati dal primo dobbiamo
concentrarci su una sola cosa su una
sola domanda che cosa ha provocato
l'incendio perché giuliano il suo lavoro
una risposta potrebbe essere perché non
abbiano sopportabile perché non me lo
ricordo che i miei colleghi
no questa non è una risposta questo e
altro
dobbiamo lasciare che la domanda stavi
dentro di noi una risposta vera sincera
potrebbe essere perché l'università ho
studiato lettere classiche avevo paura
che non avrei mai trovato lavoro quindi
mi sono buttata in questo ufficio ma
adesso capisco che per me è una gabbia
perché non c'è spazio qui non c'è pace
per la mia passione non c'è spazio per
me
ora siamo più vicini a capire cosa abbia
provocato l'incendio
meglio ancora siano vicine a capire chi
abbia provocato incendi è stata giugno è
stata quella parte di giugno e rifiuta
di essere soffocata quella parte di
giulia e ancora arte ed è sempre così
quando abbiamo a che fare con degli
incendi interiore abbiamo paura e
stappiamo sappiamo dall'incendio che noi
stessi abbiamo appiccato per bruciare
per lavora al suolo quelle parole di noi
le quali situazioni e non ci
rispecchiano c
ma non dobbiamo avere paura di quel
fuoco
sanitario perché tutte le volte che lo
richiamo non stiamo evitando qualcosa
stiamo evitando lui stessi e ci sono due
motivi per cui dovremo aver paura degli
uccelli ulteriori il primo il fuoco non
si limita a ridurre in cenere il passato
ma illumina il futuro
chiediamoci sempre cosa sta illuminando
la mia fiamma quale strada mi sta
facendo vedere il secondo motivo è che
non dobbiamo aver paura di morire né
vincendo i primi stessi abbiamo
affittato perché una volta spente le
fiamme siamo capaci di risorgere dalle
nostre ceneri e allora permettetemi di
darmi un concilio ritardi della voi ma a
me un buon film la prossima volta i mi
sentirete stanchi e vi sentirete come se
tutto fosse troppo pesante non andato in
vacanza andato incontro a voi stessi
è questo il grande messaggio di seneca